sur la route à nous écouter et écouter
les prévisions
vos points de vue c'est figaro live
dernier numéro de l'année dernier numéro
avant noël respecterait vous
scrupuleusement les consignes sanitaires
c'est la question qu'on vous pose sur le
site du figaro j'attends vos réponses
j'attends vos points de vue et avec vous
ce soir vous avez l'extrême et le grand
honneur d'avoir laurent joffrin
fondateur d'engageant nous est également
alors non je veux pas créer d'un père
vous êtes fondateur ou co fondateur dans
gall président président à président
d'ampleur une seule personne c'est pas
collégial il ya quatre associations
toutes les associations et aux loisirs
vous avez été directeur également de
libération saluent face à vous vous
aurez donc jean christophe buisson
directeur adjoint du figaro magazine qui
revient en une sur le grand réveil des
cathos c'est donc à retrouver dans le
figaro magazine de ce week-end est un
très bel hommage également on trouve à
l'intérieur
à jean pierre pernaut vous avez signé
également un apollon l'esprit des lieux
c'est une passion pour l'empereur que
vous partagez avec laurent joffrin qui a
écrit combien allait livrer sans doute
la seule mais qui a écrit combien de
livres jean laurent joffrin sur napoléon
iii 4 3 ou 4 3 ou 4 à réponse à la
demande et lui à la fin car l'émission
quatre livres est donc le dernier seul
contre tous et ses concerts a concerné
les 100 jours ils sont joueurs de
liddell s'est donc il lègue le volera du
clocher en clocher avec je voulais dire
la sauce tour ne dirais pas aussi aussi
bien vous surtout que vient de commettre
une imposture en direct puisque
j'ai demandé en fait à laurent justement
qualité le titre de son livre ce qui
n'était pas bien j'aurais dû le savoir
ça c'est pour l'histoire dans la cuve
également qui est la personnalité que
vous avez préféré s kamenar is as à
traoré joe biden comme le magazine
américain time
on attend là aussi vos réponses
respecterez vous d'abord la consigne des
six à tablât c'est la question qu'on
vous pose sur le site du figaro pour
l'instant vous êtes très légitimiste à
plus de 6 internautes sur 10 répondent
oui et ont été sensibles aux arguments
aux mises en garde peut-être du
professeur delfraissy ce matin sur rmc
on se contaminent c'est des endroits où
on enlève son masque c'est les endroits
où l'on mangé ou mon bois bon
particulier mais pas seulement où on
enlève le masque donc c'est à
l'extérieur et c'est à l'intérieur la
moitié des contaminations à peu près à
quelque chose près survient en intra
familiale où on intra amical faudra-t-il
porter un masque à la maison pendant les
fêtes
il faudrait le porter au maximum moi je
vais être comme tous les français je et
j'ai honte j'ai décidé de scinder la
famille en deux de limiter à moins de 6
et de limiter mahb le temps passé avec
la famille et je j'essaierai de garder
le mas mais je sais bien que c'est
difficile alors c'est assez difficile
oui je vous le confirme
vous êtes vous porterez le masque
jean-christophe vous êtes convaincus par
les arguments du bon professeur d'elle
fois ci je comprends c'est
je comprends ses arguments mais il ya
trop de choses que je ne comprends pas
depuis depuis des semaines de consignes
de contre consigne de nous demander
justement une consigne assez sévère qui
est de réunion de famille au moment
peut-être le plus familial de l'année le
plus heureux le plus joyeux
le plus porteur d'espoir qui est qu'est
noël qui est qu'elle annonce pour les
chrétiens de l'arrivée du christ sur
terre nous demander des consignes assez
strict portée et dans le même temps des
confiné en partie pouvoir à nouveau
voyager
quel est le message qu'on envoie est ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
mais pour tout vous dire ou es ce que
vous cire dans le même temps c'est ça
que je ne comprends pas dans la
politique du gouvernement c'est avec un
certain désordre des contrôles
permanents est ce que c'était la même
chose sur l'école pardon avec casque
castex sait pas très bien s'il fallait
aller à l'école jeudi vendredi ou pas
c'est tout le temps comme ça depuis moi
c'est ça qui est insupportable on ne
sait plus s'il faut obéir aux uns et aux
autres que les uns disent ça va mieux
les autres 17 pire en pire voilà donc je
suis un peu désarmée face à ces vous
êtes désormais vous êtes des ans par est
ce que vous êtes désarmés et désemparé
également charles or en jeu fatigués
exaspérés comme tout le monde c'est
insupportable cette affaire mais bon et
à la guerre comme à la guerre donc je
pense qu'il faut respecter les consignes
même si elles sont contradictoires
c'est comme à l'armée pas sensibles à
l'argument de
de cet internaute qui lie tout comme le
dîner de macron avant qu'ils soient
testés positifs au co vide je ne
respecterais pas le consigne de ces
adultes à table j'ai compté j'en aurai 7
donc je suis mais c'est comme à l'armée
cherchait pas obligatoire chercher à
comprendre c'est déjà désobéir
alors est-ce que devant cette profession
de foi antimilitariste de répondre à
cette profession de foi antimilitariste
de l'ancien directeur de libération mais
vous êtes une phrase très fort tant de
retraités soit bon chroniqueur militaire
je veux dire je vais respecter les
consignes même si elles sont
contradictoires mais c'est le problème
c'est le problème c'est qu'elles sont
contradictoires on peut pas recevoir des
consignes mais non moins ya des gens un
dîner moins de chance de bien surveiller
et plus en étant distances de sécurité
mais mieux c'est on est tous dans
l'absolu mais gelé la preuve ultime de
l'impossibilité d'obéir scrupuleusement
plus est malgré tout bien sûr et voilà
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec le avec le
prix de la république qui est ce qui
s'est passé mais oui je n'en peux
apprécier intelligemment nous mêmes les
conseils mais les gens du web ce qu'ils
étaient mais je pense à la grande
distance si j'ai bien compris
oui mais justement ce qui s'est passé
après six mois c'est que ceux qui
étaient très éloignées sont bien
musulman
certains sont ces sons se sont fait
tester tout de suite alors on sait très
bien que c'est qu'eux mêmes n'ont pas
compris les consignes que delfraissy
ouvert en hausse et london c'est ça
c'est ça
donc comment voulez vous exigez des
français qu'ils obéissent à des
consignes que vous même un vous ne
respectez pas en tout cas pas
scrupuleusement et 2 que vous même ne
maîtrisez pas dans leur dans l'or dans
leurs présentations c'est vrai mais il
ya eu à un rapport américain que j'ai lu
dans un article de presse à un brasier
qui a repris je sais pas le vélo c'est
pour ça que laurier s'abstient de site
le nom du journal mais
ils ont repris sur six mois c'est des
universitaires et j'ai pas tellement de
gens albi comptant le grand c'est cette
étude ils ont repris sur six mois des
râles concurrents en plus des
universitaires des non journalistes ça
fait beaucoup quand même hein on cherche
y peut rien et c'est une dialyse ont que
ça à faire d'horizon des études il a
étudié les chiffres et donc ils ont
regardé où croiser les données
sanitaires de données économiques ce
sont les pays qui ont été les plus
draconiens en matière sanitaire qui ont
payé le prix du plus moins élevées en
matière économique
c'est le contraire de ce qu'on pense
c'est contre intuitif que l'on pense
qu'à une contradiction entre l'économie
et la santé et donc on joue la santé et
on sacrifie l'économie attend en fait ce
qui n'est pas très bien le sait ce
qu'est ce qu'ils ont tirés d'emblée là
c'est tout pas santé je t'amène parce
qu'ils ont joué d'emblée la santé ont
réussi à juguler l'épidémie
et après ils ont pu relâcher l'économie
et c'est beaucoup plus rentable de faire
ça que de se dire a priori on va
aménager l'économie tant pis pour la
santé c'est comme par exemple les états
unis ont fait plutôt ça ou la grande
bretagne ou la suède
cela rompt une crise interminable et ils
paient aussi cher sinon plus que les
autres et sanitaires une crise et les
deux bas nylon les deux états unis la
crise économique est moins forte en
province sont que la nôtre et le nom de
man with him en équivalent en proportion
oui mais ça continue c'est à dire que ça
va durer indéfiniment
en france aussi on est ensemble si on
avait tellement totalement l'économie au
sort au profit de la santé oui et non
parce que les par exemple les masquant
n'ont pas été obligatoire d'emblée une
raison d'y aller parce que non mais
malgré deux victoires le gorille s'étend
l'étude sont élevées hier les critiques
qui ont été comptés draconien dès le
départ soit par les masses les gestes
barrière où les confinements et il s'en
tire mieux que l'autre se débat depuis
six mois l'économie d'un côté la
chanteuse est un débat
nourrissez vous pouvez pas exact c'est
pas moi je ne fais que répéter de la
chine ou de la corée parce que ça n'a
pas été la même réponse surtout l'accord
et surtout après ça a été moins corée
japon va tout s'effondre à cogner encore
hey oui mais en chine par exemple
laurent vous pouvez pas faire oui mais
si on prend la chine comme exemple on
est tout de suite accusé d'être un
dictateur je pars dans l'ordre là dedans
sans parler de la chine
wimereux singapour on pouvait pas mettre
vous pouvez pas ne pas tenir compte des
civilisations des cultures de la
sociologie de ces populations est l
ennemi lord howe est pas tout à fait la
même chose
la france et singapour ont vraiment
apporté à mazet pour une question de si
vous êtes déjà né à singapour
moi je suis allé plusieurs fois
singapour franchement c'est la
discipline déjà eu des épidémies d'une
part donc les bisons surtout une
discipline vous jeter un mégot de
cigarette mais les français en sont ces
disciplines et quand on leur dit non
mais non mais regardez le confinement il
était respecté pourtant c'est une mesure
liberticide par excellence moi vous
trouvez pas comme quand même ça a été
l'une des révélations de l'année c'est
qu'on craignait que les français ne
respectent pas le confinement ils l'ont
pourtant respecté probalement
globalement globalement mais moins de
manière moins disciplinés que des pays
d'asie qui ont une certaine habitude
d'avoir prend l'habitude de porter hamas
depuis des années et des années
c'est la surprise et puis un
gouvernement leur gouvernement leur dit
porter le masque pour des bonnes raisons
nous le temps que nous valons
comprennent qu'il faut porter un masque
droit - d'épidémie d'eau et ensuite
c'était une découverte pour nous
regarder
bernard henri lévy qui s'est insurgé
peut-être à juste titre contre le port
de masques ont peu plus ses rangs
sensiblement les mages mois qui nous
fixe d'ailleurs aujourd'hui maintenant
les gens numéro ce soit sur ou que ça
pose des problèmes en terme de liberté
lapidation évidemment si on fait un
bilan de fin d'année le jazz de manière
si c'est la guerre en valait 1 mais si
c'est lors il va falloir organise les
missions non mais on a offert un million
de licenciés par leur nom mais si les
passionnés résumé me base sur une
approche si on cherche à prolonger des
mois tiré leçon modèle le
la leçon que je vois moi c'est que c'est
pas tellement l'épidémie et qui est
l'événement de l'année je me mis à la
déjà une fois c'est la réaction à
l'épidémie c'est réactions dans tous les
pays du monde a quand même consistait à
dire avec des nuances martin pour
l'essentiel la santé est prioritaire
alors que vous aviez eu la même épidémie
en gravité en 1969
tout le monde l'a oublié malgré le hong
kong dont seul ministre ayant là on l'a
oublié
l'at-on l'année on a découvert qu'en
1969 il y avait pourrait dire les mots
esprits par exemple certains lecteurs du
figaro qui a une épidémie de gauchisme à
ce moment là mais vous oubliez que
l'épidémie est l'épicé dépit dé
l'épidémie
je regrette cette comparaison entre le
virus était une citation vide et la
gauche et huit dîners de macron donc on
disait tout à l'heure cet internaute et
lionel me dit être assis sa table c'est
une consigne ou une recommandation alors
là lionel c'est un peu c'est un peu
spécieux la question que vous posez en
tous les cas effectivement c'est pas
c'est pas du même ordre que le
couvre-feu ce n'est pas du même ordre
que le confinement donc c'est on va dire
que c'est les deux une consigne est une
recommandation mais ce n'est en tous les
cas pas une obligation
tatou qui nous dit 6 ou pas si sa table
il faut s'attendre à une nouvelle
flambée de cadres qu'aux vidéos
confinement après les fêtes et criss
cross pour moi noël c'est sacré qu'ovide
ou pas et j'irai à la messe de noël
aucun d'entre eux répondent à la
question que je vais vous poser est ce
que vous y avez vous faire tester avant
noël non peut-être parce que j'ai une
réunion de famille s'est tenu les a
laissés à tester l'autre sauf que je
vais encore prévues au programme et je
n'arrête pas de me faire tester quand je
pars en arménie non je pense que je suis
dit il faut pas de bons autour de cette
route moi même je les ai je eu donc oui
vous avez besoin de voir l'utilité à
vous lever des jeunes ouais ça vous a
plus besoin de vous faire tu es ce
normal que mon excellent modèle
normalement normalement en tous les cas
dans les consignes gouvernementales par
exemple concernant les ehpad où on
condamne quasiment les pensionnaires une
fois qu'ils sont sortis à rester sept
jours clos très dans leur chambre
s'ils ont été testés positifs avant le
dans les deux derniers mois ils peuvent
sortir donc non ils n'ont pas la
consigne d'être de subir justement c'est
ni une règle ning consignes une
recommandation mais une règle les sept
jours de sept jours de quarantaine en
tout cas d'isolement
question peut-être de cet internaute
peut importe les consignes supporteront
nous un troisième confinement ça va être
dur
c'est peut-être inévitable par amour
bruit de fond qu'on entend c'est on y va
tout droit parce que déjà ça remonte
maintenant après les fêtes il y aurait
eu beaucoup de contacts humains et donc
c'est presque inévitable de le mettre en
oeuvre
mois de janvier est ce que je trouve
horrible évidemment mais bon si les
idées sous la même forme que les
précédents c'est un peu un mantra chez
moi mais je ne comprends toujours pas
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à décentraliser
les
les politiques de confinement ou des
décrochages en les aidant les régions
j'avais déjà parlé soulagerait certaine
et on l'a fait une fois et on estime que
c'est un échec parce qu'on avait choisi
marseille
il marchait franchement bat marseille
quoi on commence pas une politique
surtout avec le passé de marseille 1720
la paix sous paris déjà enfermé
marseille en a déjà parlé on prend la
ville qui ne faut pas prendre pour faire
un contre une pub quelque chose qui peut
être perçu comme une punition mais je
pense que il ya tellement de disparités
dans la circulation du virus dans le
fonctionnement dans les régions entre le
fin fond du cantal et une banlieue de
seine-saint-denis où tout le monde et
empilés les uns sur les autres que c'est
complètement absurde d'avoir la même
politique sanitaire dans ces endroits
aussi différents les uns que les autres
et ça
cette espèce de d'obsession de
l'égalitarisme en france amène à 7 cette
maladie qu'on les franchissements cette
fatigue on en parlait à laurent joffrin
et cette crainte d'un troisième
confinement d'une 33e confinement qu'on
imagine encore moins bien supporté que
les précédents parce que s'il est sous
la même forme effectivement c'est
insupportable pour aller dans votre sens
ce qui est vrai c'est que ou tout début
de la crise avant même que emmanuel
macron ne décide le confinement
généralisée c'était la réponse qui avait
été donnée par exemple dans l'oise il y
avait eu un premier événement alors que
jérôme simard édifié il y avait un coût
final des charges des gouvernants même
si c'est marseille c'est vrai quand ils
font ça et ils sont pris entre deux
écueils 1
on prend des mesures globales tout le
monde dit un signe aux situations sont
différentes et il essaye d'être
d'adapter les mesures à chaque cas
particulier à ce moment là celui de
le mandingue mais pourquoi l'alsace est
pas comme nous c'est pas normal ce
samedi sur des rues seraient stigmatisés
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il y a pas un
autre risque dans ces cas là c'est que
par exemple les parisiens cilicie par
exemple les parisiens sont confinés les
bretons ne le sont pas si les parisiens
remontent en bretagne
est-ce que y'aura pas également de
nouvelles polémiques comme il y en a eu
par le passé
c'est peut-être qu'on empêche justement
parce que c'est mal les parisiens
d'aller en bretagne pendant quinze jours
trois semaines après les faits ce qui
arrive depuis des mois on empêche les
les régions d'aller nous empêchent de
circuler librement parce que le
commentaire journalistique n'est pas
toujours cohérent c'est alternatif
soyez cohérents prenez des mesures
simples quand ils prennent des mesures
simples on dit ah bah non
vous mettez tout le monde sous la toise
c'est horrible il faut il faut
distinguer nos qu'on passe de l'un à
l'autre politique qu'ils ont envie
d'être responsables politiques agricoles
parce que non j'ai toujours pensé que
même les journalistes devaient se
demander un peu quand même
qu'est ce qu'ils auraient fait s'il
avait été au gouvernement nicole et
chris kraus disent qu'ils n'iront pas se
faire tester avant noël parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de symptômes et nicole de
toute façon si on est plus de 6 à table
qui ira vérifier c'est la question que
vous posez curieusement la police
n'entre pas dans les salons est ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans sa grille canada
c'est à dire il y avait la police avait
en tout cas le doit en théorie deux et
on a dû vérifier diffusée sur fear alive
un des images de la police qui à madrid
essaye de traquer les fêtes les fêtes
clandestines donc il ya sur l'histoire
de l'analyser va être dans le
collimateur
c'est vrai que vu le précédent sommet le
président est à la lanterne sur si je
parle du lieu bien entendu si la
question de la territorialisation vous
intéresse également
sachez qu'on a fait un live hier et
qu'on pouvait retrouver en replay avec
agnès verdier molinié qui elle défend
également cette cette thèse et qui avait
fait une tribune dans le figaro qui
avait été très commentée et elles
répondent aux internautes du figaro sur
cette question et aux objections qui
sont faites sur cette question pour les
fêtes
allez-vous respecté la consigne de six
adultes à table et pour l'instant il ya
une large majorité qui répondent oui
quasiment 64%
on va passer à la deuxième question
pardonnez-moi la transition est un peu
brutal mais il est encore un peu tôt
pour lever le rideau avant la fin de
l'année mais on fait un premier bilan d'
ailleurs laurent joffrin s'est pas gêné
de le faire parce qu'ils la grid a
commencé tout à l'heure au grand dam de
jean-christophe mais version sms très
aimable qui m'a dit qu'est qu'on allait
parler du bilan
maintenant si vous donnez tous les
coulisses mais ça fait voilà c'est le
web va d'abord une question puisque
justement on en parle et vous avez
abordé cette question tout à l'heure
l'événement de l'année
c'est inconstestablement alors vous
dites pas le virus mais la réaction au
virus
comment expliquez vous que le times
n'est pas consacré sa une à une
personnalité qui s'est attaquée à ce
problème mais je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
ont fait je suis très ignorants ils ont
consacré leur une
joe biden à kamena harris assa traoré ou
démocrate
ah oui ils ont fait plusieurs accords
non mais la vraie personnalité de
l'année c'est assez trop risqué une caté
c'est une sous-catégorie sow qui était
la vraie course des tuyaux maiden et
kamenar y sous-entendu une femme
enfin un duo la chute de trump est un
événement parce que c'est vrai que c'est
personnel mais à débattre tous les
joueurs du coc vide on finit pas et donc
il a il s'est passé un événement
politique important tous les quatre ans
on change de président aux états unis et
ça a des influences sur toute la planète
donc là il est logique de dire la
victoire de bayonne est un événement
considérable surtout étant donné la
personnalité du candidat adverse
et puisque c'est la chute de tram parce
que là aussi il ya des lignes à turin
brouillard autour de ça mais qui est
entretenue par trump lui même qui a été
entretenue mais il a été battu nettement
sans aucune discussion
il a perdu 2,4 millions de voix et il a
perdu 2,70 délégué donc il ya aucun
doute il a été battu et il avait déjà
perdu les mid term elections
ce qui veut dire que il ya tout un
discours sur le thème le populisme
nationaliste sont irrésistibles il monte
il m'a dit maintenant là ils sont fait
battre et dans les règles sans appel est
donc le 36 est est un phénomène
résistible et d'une manière générale la
montée du nationalisme dans les vallées
dans beaucoup de pays on peut y arriver
à les battre
ce produit n'a été battue n'est pas du
tout répondu à la question de vincent
mais mais mais m
nous n'aimons 6 et des sports ça
l'intéresse mais la question c'est
important à cause de ça et moi juste
après le monde politique je viens d une
question c'est est pourquoi votre avis
on n'a pas mis une personnalité quad
times meilleurs salaires mais voilà et
je pense que cette question
est une très bonne question parce que
moi parce que j'ai envie de vous faire
un compliment mais parce que on est
incapables de s'entendre dire parce
qu'on est tellement désarmer des enfin
incapable de d'avoir une politique
cohérente dans le monde entier que même
les hommes et aux états unis
comme réponse à la cause vite qu'on est
incapable de sortir un médecin un
chercheur un homme politique ou une
femme politique qui aurait trouvé la
solution et qui mériterait d'être mise
en avant par rapport à cette épidémie au
delà on n'a pas les réponses aux
principales questions je pense que c'est
pour ça parce qu'il fit effectivement
cela dit le fait de m'être buydens et il
a eu une attitude à l'égard de la cause
vide car différente de celle de 10 avril
et pour pouvoir donc quand il y sera on
verra si sa politique était financé pas
augurer de l'agent mais je dis pas qu'il
sera efficace entre et il n'a pas du
tout eu la même réaction que trump
donc le fait de le mettre en avant ça
parle aussi de l'épidémie je passe oui
j'ai voulu ce qui est intéressant dans
ce que vous disiez également laurent
sais que je fais partie des choses pour
lesquelles on vous invite d'ailleurs des
réseaux entre les cas vous disiez que il
ya le brouillard du pot vide mais
derrière ça à côté de ça il ya des il ya
des événements politiques majeurs et
est-ce que alors pensez pas qu on en
fait peut-être trop sur le co lead et
que justement ça s'empêche de s'attaquer
au volet question aux vrais problèmes
ça c'est un point devant caen a pu lire
également sur sous la plume de certains
éditeurs devraient suffire aux notamment
sur les questions de condensats d'amis
c'est normal ce après que tout le monde
y compris moi même et il se passer le
monde évolue en ce temps là qu'on dise
sur le sur le diagnostic quand même que
poser tout à l'heure laurent sur le fait
que la révélation de l'année c'est que
c'est une défaite pour les populistes le
nationalisme résistible vous partager le
même point de vue sur ce rien parce que
prince on ne parle que on ne parle que
de trump
il me semble qu'ils auraient pu dire ça
l'année dernière avec départ de salvini
déjà on avait un antécédent meilleur est
peut-être premier d'un domino mais au
brésil c'est urgent ball sonar ou en
europe en trois services qui sont élus
et réélus et largement les élus s'ils
voulaient prendre de but face à l'as
plus que la pologne et la hongrie en a
plus que la non mais regardez les petits
pays la croatie slovaquie mais poussée
nationaliste mais l'inde est toujours un
père un humour nationalisme populiste la
tête de et la turquie et l'argent semble
même pas alors justement si on en parle
alors vous c'est la personnalité de
l'année erdogan suivant c'est pour
pouvoir sunnite est la plus sympathique
joue la corde mais après tout si on se
réfère des précédentes une le times
qu'on consacre en consacrant staline
l'ayatollah comédie où hitler comme
homme de l'année
ça veut dire qu'on a le droit de
désigner à partir du moment où cette
personnalité a fait bouger les choses je
pense que leur domaine est la
personnalité qui en 2020 a le plus fait
bouger le monde fait réagir le monde
avec une politique de fuite en avant qui
s'explique entre autres par l'idéologie
qui l'animent qu'un mélange d'islamisme
et de nationalistes un mélange de rêve
poste ottoman et de rêves kémaliste qui
correspond au fait que son parti a perdu
les élections en 2019 qui correspond qui
au fait qu' une crise économique majeure
mais qui correspond aussi au fait que
les états unis avec c'est justement
l'annnonce de cette élection se sont mis
en retrait du monde et puis la politique
de trump consistant à retirer à se
retirer un petit peu des affaires du
monde et que erdogan a pris une toute
puissance qui s'est manifestée tout le
long de l'année 2020 de manière très
spectaculaire en syrie avec kid libre où
ils sont confrontés à la russie au point
de finalement signer un accord à moscou
en mars en se partageant un petit peu
cette zone en libye où il est venu à la
rescousse alors à narguer la france
larguée la france tout contrat va aider
le gouvernement d'accord national en
envoyant d'ailleurs des mercenaires
syrien à l'aider à chypre où il est venu
vous voulez venu bien sûr à chypre avec
le
les mercenaires wagner à chypre nord qui
est quand même un état qui n'existe pas
qui n'est pas reconnue où il est venu
parader dans cette cité balnéaire de
varrault chat qui appartient aux grecs
où il a fait des ronds dans l'eau et que
ces bateaux pour dire que maintenant
toutes les zones de forage gazier dans
la région dans cette région là au
prétexte que c'était proche des côtes
turques ça lui appartenait à que ça
appartient historiquement à la grèce
enfin la zone autour de chi à
sainte-sophie le 10 juillet où il entre
dans sainte-sophie retransforme sainte
sophie qui était de nos musées depuis
kemal en mosquée et il fait comme mémé
deux entrants à constantinople en 453 il
fait une prière musulmane pour bien
montrer que sainte sophie c'est lui et
ensuite ils aident alief à attaquer les
pauvres arméniens de l'artsakh du haut
karabakh a utilisé des drones des
mercenaires syrien et toute une flopée
de deux technologies écrasant les
arméniens et redonne c'est tout ça pour
le long de l'année c'est spectaculaire
c'est impressionnant c'est dangereux
c'est dangereux parce que à chaque fois
qu'on veut éventuellement lui dire il
faut pas faire ça il ya quatre millions
de réfugiés chez moi donc m'embêtait pas
sinon je vous le robinet je vous envoie
en europe ok donc j'avance et il
continue et au moment où je vous parle
il est en train de menacer l'arménie
elle même la république d'arménie de
grappiller le sonic et la région du
sud-est de l'arménie qui arménienne et
dont il a besoin pour faire son fameux
corridor turque entre eux istanbul et
look signant si ça c'est pas la
personnalité et je rajouterais la plus
dangereuse du moment en ce moment je ne
sais pas ce qu'il faut la suite des
informations d'ailleurs sur l'arménie
sur twitter sur le compte de jean
christophe buisson qui justement
alimente en informations ceux qui sont
intéressés par la situation dans le
caucase
laurent sur ce que vient de dire
jean-christophe du jour qu'il a pas tort
c'était un des plus dangereux bien sûr
mais son importance géopolitique est
considérable il ya c'est comme poutine l
empire dezza alors on retrouve l'empiré
ottoman alors qu'ils y aient kriss kross
rejoignent jean christophe buisson me
dit on pour eux c'est erdogan qui est la
personnalité pour vous c'est la terre de
gan qui a la personnalité de l'année
alors qu est-ce qui vous a dit que c'est
fait le professeur raoul également bon
et ben on peut en débattre c'est avec
respect et alors un peu moins dangereux
que les avec respect va provoquer
laurent joffrin puisqu'il dit je dirais
que la personnalité de l'année cette rom
pour avoir persuadé les régimes arabes
de se réconcilier avec israël
ah oui embêter la non pas du tout parce
que c'est eux et de peu il a
certainement conclure des compromis ou
faire en sorte que ces ans agréé avec
certains pays arabes
mais dernièrement mais alors il va en
effet reculé il a fait reculer le
règlement israélo-palestinien de
plusieurs étapes considérable vous
pouvez pas nier que quand même il ya eu
quand même je n'ai rien du tout des des
avancées dans certains pays notamment
l'arabie saoudite et notamment gildas
qui fait dire à dire leers qu'entre
comme trump est horrible en général dès
qu'il fait une chose un peu de bon sens
on dirait un formidable outil incroyable
il a fait une chose bien oui évidemment
il est bon on est président on fait pas
que des choses mal
après pour le reste c'était un désastre
complet et ce qu'on apprend en vérité là
tu j'aimerais savoir quels quelles sont
les conditions qui ont été mises pour
ces reconnaissances je craque et des
conditions financières
assez assez noir plus le flash des
informations
donc et steve également vous répond la
chute de trump mais non il a eu 75
millions de voix c'est pas une chute il
a perdu les élections
qu'est ce qui fait que ce qu'il faut de
plus pour vous la pluie il est pas mort
je juge accord pour il a survécu aux
convives pour vous la personnalité de
l'année c'est la première ministre néo
zélandais oui voilà ce que moi je vois
midi et la porte est donc je conseillais
à bruxelles peu loin quand même assez
exactement quel âge horaire à midi il
n'est pas la sublime et pas juste mais
je savais que j'allais faire preuve dans
la chaîne alimentaire la surintendance à
choix c'est seulement le jeu les
munitions je vous prie d'écouter mes
nouvelles voyez c'est une jeune femme et
les plus jeunes que macron elle vient de
l a été
c'est un petit pays dont ils sont 4
millions c'est aux antipodes jeu mou la
corde mais c'est un pays moderne c'est
un pays sur lequel on n'accorde pas
jeter un oeil plus plus plus précis elle
a été élu une première fois dans une
coalition deuxième mandat c'est quand
même assez rare dans la démocratie
actuelle
elle a gagné c'est la gagne et de son
parti le parti travailliste donc aparté
a gagné 50% à lui tout seul donc elle a
progressé de 15 points d'une amende à
sur l'autre on la connaît parce qu'elle
a eu une attitude extrêmement dignes et
compassionnelle au moment de l'attentât
le terrible col de christchurch
on la connaît moins par le fait qu'elle
mène une politique dans ce pays donc
moderne qui est une politique très
intéressante est à marquer d'une
politique d'avenir
c'est à dire que là elle a remplacé les
populistes
non attendez elle a remplacé le pib
auquel on se referme partout par un
indicateur de bien-être pour la
population et le budget néo zélandais
est calculé en fonction de ses effets
sur le bien-être et non pas de ses
effets directs uniquement sur la
croissance et ça c'était une un message
d'avenir pour nos démocraties à nous
parce que compte tenu du réchauffement
climatique de la question
environnementale de la question sociale
on ne peut pas se contenter de compter
les richesses qu'on a
il faut aussi compter leurs effets sur
le bien-être donc contemporain vous êtes
vous succombez pas aux charmes de jalons
de ce film est une femme de gauche qui
viennent des élections jeu le plus grand
respect michel rubio là nous savons
qu'il avait annoncée de ce qu'elles ne
resteraient pas par contre on a fait
semblant de pas longtemps mais moi non
je quittais le bhoutan où le houleux le
népal qui avait déjà un espèce d'un
indice du bonheur espèces mais on peut
quand on a un petit indice ben là on
veut quand on est une île un petit pays
40 morts isolé est prête nous le
rapporte que je pense que vous peut pas
faire ça dans tous les pays du monde à
commencer par la france
vous pourriez pas faire et ce qu'on
n'est pas une île parce qu'on n'est pas
un pays homogène de dante dans tous les
domaines normale possible exempt de
savoir si la politique du gouvernement
améliore la vie quotidienne mais qu'on
cite si on avait déjà un ministère du
loisir on est un mystère du bien-être
qu'on reviendra au pouvoir avec votre
ami françois hollande c'est ça que vous
nous promet de nous vendre du rêve le
range mais avec notre ami françois
hollande c'est pas la question
la gauche doit revenir pouvoir elle peut
revenir au pouvoir là une chance pour
certains ministères du bien-être mais
non de faire en sorte que la politique
budgétaire l'action publique soit tourné
non pas uniquement c'est important
d'avoir des prospère le niger ne pas
avoir de les dettes que l'on laissé
françois hollande et rémy c'est déjà pas
mal changé et c'est le vide qui a fait
le poids de la dette
et pour ce qui est de la situation de la
population française c'est ça me paraît
logique de mesurer
pauvreté l'inégalité la santé etc pour
voir si le gouvernement améliore la vie
de ses concitoyens une autre ou non sont
forcément le formaliser comme ça on le
sait pour prouver leur nom on n'a pas
d'indicateur globale non on va le débat
public est installée parce qu'on se
fonde sur le pib au nom il y aura deux
indicateurs à égalité un qui est plus
fiable qu'est le pib parce que c'est de
l'argent c'est plus facile à compter et
un autre qui s'occupe des gens de
l'humanité le jeu je vous recommande la
chronique de charles jaigu dans le
figaro d'hier qui fait le la critique
d'un livre qui dit comment la france a
décroché économiquement ou comment elle
a sacrifié son économie en voulant
financer son pacte social jours commence
le débat et c'était le débat non mais
c'était le débat s'était dit hier
justement et parce que justement
notamment charles critiqué la notion de
protectionnisme on a été un peu provoc
également posant en posant la question
de savoir si c'était parce que la france
avait été trop protectionniste quand on
est arrivé c'est cette situation là je
vous renvoie au point de vue d'hier
c'est quand la dernière question que je
quand même les questions subsidiaires je
voulais vous poser et si vous appréciez
également à cette première ministre néo
zélandaise parce que d'après ce que j'ai
compris il avait été élu d'abord avec
des écologistes en coalition donc en
union de la gauche et qui va après la
gagner tout seul là vous allez vous
allez loin la protection de l'autre oui
enfin c'est une socialiste quoi voix la
socialiste réformiste comme moi et ça
c'est un peu votre idéal 2
de la gauche que c'est quelque chose
qu'à de mieux dans la vie politique sont
les gens qui font des réformes utiles à
nos concitoyens que lionel jospin
n'écoute pas cette émission-là el fâcher
la perspective mais en tout cas si l'on
salue l'ancien premier ministre bien
entendu le la perspective pour 2021
qu'est ce que vous allez suivre en
particulier
vous parlez de quoi là qu'est ce que je
vais suivre quelle justement est-ce que
vous allez il faut que je vais
m'intéresser à la politique française la
politique française c'est mon péché
mignon
l'arménie à l'hermine évidemment
prioritairement de le mois de janvier
parce que cette situation et est loin
d'être terminée et pour finir sur une
note légère les jeux olympiques le
championnat d'europe de football et
c'est à la prospective peut-être autour
de la du coronavirus comment vous voyez
les choses comment les choses peuvent
évoluer
j'ai confiance dans les autorités
sanitaires de mon pays
malgré tout les palinodies qu'elles ont
plus subi et donc je pense que le vaccin
va quand même à la fin des fins
améliorer les choses pour
jean-christophe willeboordse est partagé
cette confiance je partage je partage
les mêmes réserves et la même confiance
mesurée dans dans le wagon et c'est vrai
qu'il ya une campagne honteuse de
l'extrême droite contre l'idée même de
deux campagnes de vaccins ce n'est pas
que les compotes à l'entrée de faire ça
pas que mon principalement quand même ce
matin et je l'entendais où il ya eu le
fameux fabien roussel dont il m'a
échappé qu'il était d'extrême droite qui
était quand même assez
il ya aussi moderato cantabile mais
mélenchon
mélenchon n'est pas d'écran qui n'est
pas l'ex amant émis des doutes en compte
qu'on s'interroge sur le vaccin ce nom
c'est un nouveau avec ça mais con con un
style l'idée que ces vaccins ne servent
à rien ou qui sont dangereuses c'est une
folie irresponsable donc ça c'est
totalement passée payé les secours
et c'est nier le fait qu' il ya eu un
essai quand même dans quarante mille
personnes
il s'est avéré que d'un côté il y avait
huit patients infectés et de l'autre 262
donc j'ai caisse contre dès qu'on parle
il ya un côté hissé le port laurentiis
laurent vous n'êtes pas net n'est pas
naïf on n'est pas tombé de la dernière
pluie ne vient que mélenchon dernier des
vrais que surfer sur la mairie durant ce
procès le jury salue reprocher dégager
les tous et son slogan vide errants et
le surf là dessus je pense qu'il ya
libye il pense pas du tout enfin ce
serait n'importe quel autre sujet il
ferait la même chose
pensez vous que ça traoré était l'une
des personnalités de l'année comme le
prétend le magazine américain time
et là effectivement votre réponse alli
sans appel en tous les cas celles qui
sont exprimées sur twitter c'était pas
forcément la communauté des fans d'un
centre havrais puisque c'est 88 % de non
peut-être dans la liste pour le père
noël quelques livres que vous
recommandez peut-être puisque on essaie
de vendredi lecture le hashtag qu'est-ce
que vous visez qu'est-ce que vous
recommanderiez aujourd'hui à jugon un
livre tout à fait originale qui
s'appelle haschich la honte de la
république s'est fait par un garçon qui
est le patron du mouv fallu le radios de
radio et qui connaît très bien les
milieux de des cités de la banlieue le
rap etc et jeunesse française
d'aujourd'hui au sens large et il
explique je sais que ça va pas plaire
aux lecteurs du figaro mais il explique
en quoi faire les faits eux je
caricature pas enfin je connais leurs
idées et il explique que la manière dont
on gère la question du cannabis en
france est désastreuse
là il ne dit pas qu'il faut légaliser
durant demain mais l'effet de
prohibition est mais le pire en pire
est on en train de laisser se constituer
des mafias avec un chiffre d'affaires
considérable avec des
les milices de tueurs le tortionnaire et
on aura on va mettre une génération à
s'en débarrasser le livre s'appelle
haschich mashish la honte de la
république la république jean-christophe
vous fait une très très trop corporate
mais honnêtement le plus beau cadeau à
faire c'est le livre de jean cia c'est
l'histoire de france parler car tout est
très beau livre très belle histoire de
france par la géographie par sans carte
des origines jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui
je fais la crise et gilet jaune et qui
explique ça je pense que c'est le genre
de choses que vous avez beaucoup laurent
joffrin qui explique parce que
l'histoire s'explique aussi par la
géographie par l'évolution géographique
des frontières et c'est un livre qui est
publié chez perrin et je trouve
absolument remarquable alors j'ai laissé
sur mon bureau mais ils et c'est un très
beau livre je confirme pas ce que parce
que j'en sais bien qu de chevet il est
dans l'édition mon bureau et il figure
en bonne place son bureau je vous
promets je montrais photo sur twitter
sinon vous avez effectivement dans le
même ordre d'idée l'éloge de la
politique
donc c'est soit direction de vincent
trémolet de villers
les grandes oeuvres de platon à
soljenitsyne ans lui par certain nombre
de signatures du du figaro ou bien de
personnes qui contribuent au figaro sur
la direction de jean-christophe buisson
et guillaume tabard les grandes figures
de la droite de la révolution française
à nos jours et c'était extrêmement
intéressant vous l'offrir est bien
laurent mais il est dédicacé les cieux
la foudre le garde bien mais non les
dégâts c'est par jean-christophe à très
beau livre alors là effectivement on n'a
pas encore parlé mais ce qui s'appelle
donc la lune éclaire la légion étrangère
ou au combat c'est un très très joli
livre qui est écrit dans par plusieurs
officiers de les jeux en particulier le
colonel pierre henry aubry
qui dit l'opération sur les opérations
exactement donc ça se passe ça commence
on commence bien sûr dans la vallée de
tagab pas bien sûr mais on commence dans
la vallée de tagab en afghanistan et ça
se termine dans la région de ménaka au
mali avec un très bel hommage bien sûr
c'est la légion étrangère à cameron
c'est sur un très beau papier également
c'est aux belles lettres collection
mémoires de guerre donc la lune éclaire
donc c'est tellement clair qu'on
n'arrive pas à voir la sur la couverture
mais vous le retrouverez et puis
également ça c'est pour laurent joffrin
jeu il est dédicacé je le donnerai ces
recours position
le nouveau monde populiste d'alexandre
ii vecchio qui compterait un grand
contributeur à point de vue bien sûr les
le dernier livre donc sur napoléon 2
jean christophe est également de laurent
seul contre tous ces très belles
éditeurs et puisqu'on en est aux mots
sauvages et aux alors une pensée une
prière également pour notre ami denis
tillinac et on vous signale son dernier
roman posthume qui raconte les trente
dernières années il est paraît-il
magnifique et c'est d'aileurs mais un
portrait de la france de l'ère
mitterrand à nos jours ça s'appelle le
patio bleus et puisqu'on en est aux
hommage aux personnalités de l'année et
bien au revoir à notre confrère jean
pierre pernaut et on va écouter
justement son sont nos revoir aux
téléspectateurs et après un petit cadeau
de la famille lefebvre
vainqueur sur m6 de l'édition 2022 la
france a un incroyable talent c'est
l'interprétation du dormillouse où
chants de noël venu de norvège qui a
retrouvé sur youtube bonne bonne fête de
noël est également à l'année prochaine
le 4 janvier vous retrouverez ici même
guillaume roquette s'il nous fait pas
faux bond du sila sophie adore les
régions je laisse les clés de la maison
volontiers est une maison qui est en
très bonne état marie-sophie merci à
tous ce dernier au revoir je vous
souhaite un joyeux noël
malgré les difficultés vivement la
prochaine année je vous embrasse du fond
du coeur merci je vous aime je vous
oublierai jamais à toi de jouer
marie-sophie
[Musique]